[Music]
my name is pj catalano i'm a master
model builder here at legoland
california resort i've been working at
legoland california for eight years now
and i absolutely love it i can't think
of doing anything else i love my work i
love physically building lego i love the
actual job
[Music]
we wear steel tele boots here at
legoland because we don't want to step
on any lego yeah there's a funny joke
that we always hear parents always come
in all the time asking you know how do
you know do you step out i'm like well
we do stuff but we have shoes on here so
it doesn't hurt
lego has passed the test of time because
it's so diverse it does everything if
you're mathematical it's all math you're
counting everything you i don't have odd
bricks i have to make audit of one odd
piece and even basis all math but it's
all artistic also like wait i have to
make a round object out of square brick
how do i do that so it's left and right
brain and people that can do both love
it even more but it's also creative in a
way where you can tell 10 different
people build a duck and you're gonna
have 10 different ducks but each duck is
gonna look like a duck
so when we get a project or a building
the first thing to do is we have to know
the size we need the footprint so what's
what's that going to be once we have
that then we have the basic idea of
where to start from how big is going to
be how tall is going to be how creative
is going to be
so depending on the model that we have
is how we prep for that model you can
see behind me all the different shelves
of colors and brick that we do have they
are sorted by piece so that's what we
standardly carry in the shop itself we
also have an entire warehouse in the
back of the park
lego now makes 62 colors there's over
100 colors in the history and there's
over 17 000 elements that they make
each color doesn't come in every piece
every piece doesn't have every color
[Music]
so you want to get down to the basics
first so the very most basic thing is
you have plate and brick
three plates as you can see right there
equals one brick so that's the most
basic thing that everyone should know or
could know that's the easiest thing to
learn so once you have that down you
could learn that four plates in a tile
will actually be the exact math of two
studs and that is an example of our snot
it's not immediate studs are not up top
so now you're viewing it that lego from
a sideway instead of a direct up and
down way so once you know that three
plates you will brick and that four
plates in a tile or two studs you can
get real complicated and you can start
building things like our snotted letters
and now it's not letters we can do the
whole alphabet in numbers and it's the
most basic small so we can do each
letter but if you look throughout
legoland mini land california you will
see all sorts of snotted and studs out
and studs up signs out there especially
using this basic technique
[Music]
so these are all considered elements so
you can see all these pieces have studs
in the top but also on the side and once
you have all the elements figured out
you have a whole other group of
amazing pieces which could be anything
in the world we got sloped we've got
angles we've got wedges we've got
minifig accessories we've got rounded
pieces we have the actual minifigs boxes
and containers angles support structures
designed pieces the positives are
endless
except for the limits of the actual
colors in the piece because remember you
never cut lego and you never paint lego
i think one of the greatest things about
working here and the most fun is that
it's never the same thing there's many
different paths a model could start on
it can be from higher ups this is what
we want here this is exactly the size
and the parameters we want and from
there might be okay you design it or
we're going to have it designed by
another team and then you guys are going
to build it and install it sometimes
okay we want something like this here
and what are your ideas and we can 100
creativity go for it sometimes just walk
around the park and look at something
and say wow that needs a rehab let's go
fix it up and then we can either copy
build it and just do exactly as is or
maybe like oh there's new colors there's
new parts it's an older model let's
redesign it let's change the color or
make some new pieces or make it a little
more new age
so i am working on a brick built lego
model this one is a
future project coming up a lego dinosaur
brick built means basically there's not
these specialty pieces and specialty
elements it's mostly just the brick and
plate
and majority is going to be studs up as
you're building so we start from the
ground floor and go up
i am working off a file off of this one
that was designed we do it layer by
layer
one of the things to remember is that if
there's brick and plate three plates
equal one brick so you could do every
single layer to plate that'll take a lot
of time so we do it by brick by brick if
possible and fill in the gaps with the
plate to save time save space and
product
this particular dinosaur took about two
two and a half days started earlier this
week should take about a week i'd say so
when he's finished he'll be
about that big
we have a system we want to build the
strongest possible models they gotta
withstand kids elements weather animals
so we have a structure called north
south east west so what that is is every
other layer changes so one layer would
be east-west one's would be north-south
and you want to criss-cross every single
layer uh we have to modify that
obviously you can't do every single
piece perfectly but we do that to the
best you can do to make the strongest
model so i'm looking at and thinking
about i'm like okay this way this way
this way this model of this this brick
can go this way this brick can go this
way and then okay next layer north and
south okay this can go this way they can
go this way but that's gonna modify this
way and do you put a two by plate first
or two one by plates so literally every
brick is a different situation so you
have to think about what's gonna be the
quickest strongest best way to build the
model
viewer to continually stack brick on top
of each other one direction and just
kind of get your get the best smile you
want it look really cool and you have
this really neat design
it's not gonna be all that strong
because it could break in many different
ways and different positions but if you
have stuff crisscrossed and now you have
less seams going up
it'll be much much stronger so the less
seams you have the stronger model is
going to be
every single brick that we use is from a
set once a month we actually get an
order list an excel sheet from lego and
actually has every single item of every
single color and every single part that
they have so that way any model out
there in the park could in theory be
built by anybody in the public so they
could see and they could build it so
it's not nothing special nothing made up
specifically for us it's all possibly
with enough sets and enough money then
you can build any of these sets also
i love coming to work and just building
thinking about it's great i like
thinking about also but when i'm just
building i just zone out i don't pay
attention anything all i can think about
is the numbers and the build and let's
do this let's do that and would this be
a better way to do it would that be a
better way and i can go this way now or
that way and add this or do this and
also i know what eight hours went by
like i can't go home yet i'm not
finished with the building yeah i want
to keep building and the second is just
seeing the kids reaction like kids and
families in general reaction to cool
models you see kids inspired and adults
are in awe they're like wait that's lego
that's amazing so it's really cool to
see reactions when they come to the park
so our tool kit is pretty basic it's our
hands because that's what we need to put
everything together
we do have a rubber mallet and that's
for at the end of every level making
sure everything's hit down all the way
proper you can push down as much as you
want with your hands but you're always
going to miss a stud so the hammer is
key and we do have a pair of special
lego pliers with little teeth at the end
and that way you could grab by the stud
if you need to remove something much
easier than you can with your fingers
and two homemade tools that we get to
make is our
stud and plate and brick counter so stud
one is studs up vertical and it shows
you the lengthwise how many studs it
could be just by marking each different
colored tile that you put on top or a
plate and brick one which is also studs
up but counts it vertically instead of
horizontally and that way you can see
exactly how many bricks and plates it is
so when we're building a model and
designing a model for the parks we have
to think about things like do we want
this to move do we want it to light up
do we want any animation to it
we have an entire animation team that
helps win that department alone so on
top of just the team that builds the
models now we have the animation team
that makes a move or makes them light up
but as far as movement and animation
that's up to us do we want this to move
should this move can we make it move
what would be really cool do we need
electric wire through it to light up so
our legoland mini land usa if you go
there at night
you can see all the lights turn on and
see all these buildings come to life and
all the buildings light up so it's
really cool street lights come on and
the car lights come on
so while we're building we have to say
okay do we need to have a wire run
through this model if we do is there an
easy way to do is we need to build a
channel for is there a way to hold it in
place it doesn't fall we don't want
people to see the wire so we have lego
techniques and maybe using a technic
brick where a wire sits through it or
maybe like a loop or maybe we can just
zip tie it so if you're walking around
legoland california seeing all the
models realize that every single model
has so much stuff inside of it also a
lot more than just what you're seeing
there's a lot of integrity inside a lot
more goes into it than just a lego model
so to become a legoland master model
builder is actually a really cool
process before you even get to the
interview you have to go to assessment
an assessment is where you actually have
three builds where you competitively
build for times and speeds and you're
not building sets like from a store
you're building models that previous
master model builds have built
my personal three-dimensional object was
actually this exact apple most of us had
to build this apple at the time it took
us a half hour now as we've all been
building here together for a while we
actually have fun competition to see who
can build it faster we've got our times
down much lower so i'm going to do that
right now with you and see how long it
actually takes to build it
and your time starts now
[Music]
some of this is coming back to me
because i kind of remember but some of
them
wait a minute
messed up
it's okay to mess up because we all do
it
and lego so it's always fixable
and that's part of the job
[Music]
and finished
[Applause]
we don't normally get applause like that
we finish a model
so how do you feel about your time on
that one
10 minutes
not too bad it's not my fastest time but
there's a lot of cameras on me right now
it's hard to envision doing anything
else i think about like is someday my
career gonna have to change i'm gonna
have to do something different i'm like
i hope not because i don't want to
i'd like to keep doing this for as long
as i can stay young at heart and have
fun
[Music]
we often have kids come and say how do
we get to do this it's how do i become a
master model builder
and i tell them keep building don't stop
building have fun get a set build it by
the instructions play with it take it
all apart mix it with all your brick
build something on your own have fun
don't just do what one thing just have
fun with it there's no limits to lego
for me it's just a giant hobby that i
love doing every day legoland itself is
an amazing place to work amazing
co-workers it's a fun environment all
time we're in a room filled with lego
bricks and toys like we're having fun
every day